the single worst moment of my life was
the moment i was born i wish that were
true but as a software engineer i've
experienced far worse things during
technical interviews if you're lucky
enough to survive tutorial hell before
the age of 25 and find a way to impress
the algorithms that automatically read
your resume you get dropped into a
high-stakes life or death game with a
six-figure salary on one side and orbeez
on the other you can tell yourself the
interview process is broken and maybe it
is but like most things in life you
can't control it and just have to play
the game in today's video you will
experience the psychological
rollercoaster ride that is the technical
interview along the way you'll learn the
secrets to high pressure problem solving
on the spot and how to impress the
interviewer even if you totally suck at
writing code to make this
hyper-realistic i've invited a special
guest who's conducted hundreds of
interviews in the real world let the
story begin
it's been a long difficult year of
hashtag learn to code i've turned down
dates with beautiful women stopped doing
flat earth research and even cancelled
netflix all for the opportunity to stare
at a computer screen for the rest of my
life thanks to this awesome video i
watched on youtube i finally landed an
interview with big scary tech
corporation i've got dozens of leak code
questions and a bunch of half finished
udemy courses under my belt nothing can
stand in my way now i'm about to jump on
this call and change my life forever
hello mr fireship my name is the primes
in welcome to hell welcome to hell
i'm just kidding i'll be conducting your
interview today you know let's just get
straight into it i'm going to ask you
actually a classic question it's called
fizzbuzz i want you to print out numbers
1 through 100 but if it's divisible by 3
i want you to print out fizz if a number
is divisible by 5 please print out buzz
but if it's divisible by both 3 and 5
please print out fizz and buzz fizzbuzz
how cliche is that i mean i just built
my own compiler in javascript last night
this is too easy
wait a minute i have no idea what i'm
doing here hash map link list mom mom
why am i so dumb wait directed graph i i
can't do it i'm just going to tell them
i can't do it binary tree i'm an
imposter i'm blacking out a few moments
later
uh mr fireship before we write any code
uh let's just talk about the problem how
would you kind of approach a problem
like this you know what i think i've
already failed this interview which
means i don't care anymore and magically
when i stop caring the anxiety goes away
screw the code let's just talk about the
problem okay so it looks like we have
three conditions here and when we have
conditions we use a conditional
statement like if one way i could
represent this is with a flowchart on a
whiteboard or if that's not an option i
might start by writing some pseudocode
because i don't want to worry about
syntax or boilerplate before i even know
what i'm going to implement for each
iteration of a loop we have a number if
it's divisible by 3 and 5 we print
fizzbuzz otherwise if it's divisible by
3 we print fizz or if it's divisible by
5 we print buzz and finally just print
the number if none of these are true wow
so this is actually a very simple
problem when we take the time to break
it down i was totally overthinking it i
was expecting something with a really
complex solution because this is big
scary tech corporation after all you
know i can't give you the answers but i
do really want to see you succeed so
feel free to ask questions as we go
along that solution looks pretty good so
how would you take that and turn it into
code i'm most comfortable in javascript
so i'll go ahead and use that for the
implementation first we'll need a loop
that iterates 100 times as i'm writing
this code i'm not thinking about getting
things done quickly but rather i'm
taking my time and making sure i fully
understand the requirements before
wasting my time writing a bunch of code
that i'll have to correct later what's
really important is that i think out
loud and explain my decisions throughout
the process normally i like to use four
each for loops but in this case i'm
going to use a traditional for loop and
not four each because i happen to know
that four will result in better
performance now even if what i'm saying
isn't totally correct it's important for
the interviewer to understand my
problem-solving process saying something
is almost always better than saying
nothing at all unless of course you say
some dumb ass in which case it may be
optimal to just shut the [ __ ] up before
you set foot into the thunderdome you
should practice literally saying
everything out loud as you solve a
problem personally i hate talking while
i write code and it just takes a lot of
practice to get comfortable with this
follow the abc rule i just made up which
doesn't mean always be coding but always
be chatting another tip is that if you
get confused and freeze up don't just
sit there but try to come up with a
question the longer you sit there and
stare at the headlights the more likely
you are to lose your composure can't
have anyone freak out out there okay
we've gotta keep our composure we've
gone too far there's too much to lose
composure i'm a little confused here so
i might ask a question like should the
program take an input and return an
answer for a specific index or should it
always iterate over all 100 answers
good question a loop is just fine now i
feel like i'm going in the right
direction so what i'll do next is create
a few conditional statements that line
up to what i sketched out on the
whiteboard now the tricky thing about
fizzbuzz is determining if one number is
a multiple of another number i guess i
could divide by the target number and if
it's an integer it's a match but if it's
a decimal then it's not a match that
should work so when it's 3 will log fizz
when it's 5 will lock buzz but if it's
false on both of these then we'll just
console log the number yeah i think that
looks good let's go ahead and use bun to
run it just to show off my knowledge of
blazingly fast javascript tooling and
yes it works perfectly i'm a goddamn
genius interesting what can you do
without magical type conversion do you
know what modulo is ah man he's not
impressed at all i'm such a loser modulo
i've never even heard that word in my
life oh wait are you talking about the
remainder operator in javascript yeah
you do have the modulo operator correct
why don't you give it a try yeah that
would make more sense here what it does
is give us the remainder when doing
division so if that number is 0 then we
know that it's a multiple of whatever
number we're trying to divide by that
gives us a solution that isn't so
dependent on the loosely type nature of
javascript it's usually a good idea to
avoid language specific magic the
interviewer might be a c developer with
50 years of experience who's going to
think your clever little javascript
tricks are mid af the modulo operator is
available in basically every language so
it's best to stick with that this is
looking pretty good but can you make
fizzbuzz print on a single line oh yeah
that's kind of not correct is it okay i
think i have an idea but i remember
reading this article that's messing with
my head right now that said the else
keyword is an anti-pattern maybe i
should stop believing everything i read
on the internet let's give it a try and
talk through it we'll first check for
the fizz buzz condition then use if else
a couple times to check for fizz and
buzz and then finally we'll use else to
log the number itself not only does this
put fizz buzz on a single line but the
code is just more simple now in fact i
don't think it can get any better oh
that looks correct now what happened if
i wanted to add some more conditions
let's say 7 is bass how are you going to
deal with that ah man i knew it else
statements really are garbage always
believe everything you read on the
internet it's never failed me when you
have a lot of conditions to check one
thing you generally want to do is try to
extract the data out of that statement
we can easily do that here by defining a
variable for the thing we want to print
now we could set up a switch statement
to check all the different conditions
but i think using if is just as good if
not better as you can see here i have
github copilot enabled but let's just
keep that on the download because i
really need this job now instead of
console logging here we'll just mutate
the variable this allows us to eliminate
the fizz buzz check and can also scale
better if we decide to add additional
words to it impressive
very nice impressively very nice
blazingly correct now how would you
describe the performance of your
algorithm i would describe it as strong
to quite strong as you can see when i
run it there's almost no lag time
because my holistic approach is so
blazingly fast well that's one way to
describe it i was more talking about big
o time complexity oh yeah i guess i
should have studied big o a little
better before doing this interview
if the fizzbuzz game were to go on
forever i'd say we have linear time
complexity or o of n however technically
the game is only played for 100 steps
which would simplify down to 01 or
constant time
wow i can't believe it's been an hour
already i blacked out where the hell am
i is this heaven oh hey congratulations
you've got the job here's your offer
sheet with a 400 000 salary and the job
is fully remote with unlimited vacation
time your first task you'll be working
on is changing all of the blue buttons
to a slightly different color blue
wow i can't believe it i've spent the
last two years pouring my blood sweat
and tears into this and my mom is going
to be so proud
hold on just one second
[Music]
uh
it looks like we've just implemented a
hiring freeze
um i'm gonna have to rescind that offer
congratulations now you know how to bomb
your technical interview just like me
make sure to subscribe to the primogen
for more awesome developer content
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one